so this week we had a lovely woman um
running for senator
oh no she is a senator oh my god so
democrats
convenient of course always the
democrats
rhode island state senator tierra mack
ripped for video of herself twerking
a rhode island state senator is getting
ridiculed for posting a campaign video
of her twerking upside down a barely
there
bikini
democrat here tierra mack 28 used her
official
district tick tock page on the 4th of
july to post the saucy clip of her
shaking her booty while in a handstand
on a beach that asks that ass
that ass someone can be heard yelling
admiringly before mac wearing a skimpy
yellow bikini turns the camera and begs
vote senator mack the state senator
advertised the clip as a promised
senator thirst trap at block island
it was just one
she posted in the revealing outfit
during her beach trip another asking how
many nip slips she was allowed oh there
was more so this is a a nice clip we got
um okay you already have three one of
her teased max who described her as a
black queer woman
max tweet twerk
max twerk quickly racked up more than 70
000 views with one admirer saying i'm
admirer saying i need to see some more
politicians doing this
tempted to move to rhode island just to
say this is my senator another fan wrote
as others sealed their support look at
her looking all happy
naysayers however quickly ripped her for
needing to reply on a tacky stunt to get
votes if this is what's running for our
country we are in serious trouble when
commander wrote well another said if her
opponent doesn't use this video then do
they want to win
another accused of her of having set the
race back years with this well another
told her i don't ever want to hear you
complain about how women aren't
respected in this country after posting
this
taco tucker carl
tucker carlson was among those poking
fun at mac's performance playing the
clip on fox news saying that
sarcastically that her demonstrated
talent proved she was the next rising
star in the democratic party
so guys um
we're gonna stop my screen share
and just get your get your takes what do
you guys think
i want to see lori lightfoot next
[Laughter]
no please no it was laurie lightfoot oh
my gosh
she's the worst she's the mayor she's
the governor the mayor of chicago she's
the mayor of chicago okay she looks like
beetlejuice
oh i mean i should know this i do i'm
from chicago i know this lady i've seen
her face i didn't know
she's beetlejuice don't say it
would she
maybe i don't know remember she had the
halloween costume and she did she looked
like the thickest superhero like she
looked like she got the vid but okay
anyhow those are that's what i think i
want to see lori lightfoot next since
like that's what we're doing we're
twerking for votes it's not enough
it's not enough to do the mailing stuff
but you know i'll be less controversial
on this channel
um but we hate women sorry keep going
keep going
no but honestly i think it's funny that
the whole female empowerment thing
really rides on twerking and
you know showing your tits off like
that's really how you get the point
across
so you know kudos to her i guess like
she's getting the attention that she
wants and that's literally why she
posted on the tick tock like why would
you post on your political page and if
you're a senator why would you even post
twerking in the first place like
you're a senator who's going to take you
seriously now they've all seen your
ass
like shaking
you know what though i wouldn't be upset
if aoc did it though like i'm okay with
that no aoc needs to shut up and never
speak again okay i'm so sorry
i do not like her it's videos like this
that make me want to return our right to
vote
i don't i people be like oh like you
wanted equal rights because i did this
video where i said that you know women
shouldn't be in combat and all these
guys are angry they're like no you
wanted this i'm like i didn't ask for
none of that driving i don't even think
i should have a driver's license like no
offense it's just like not my forte it's
like the right to vote i'd give it up
because women trend toward communism
like they vote with fifi's like no thank
you no thanks especially like how many
dumb women are gonna be like you know
what i'm gonna vote for this lady just
twerking on tick tock like that's
y'all
come on i'll take one for the team i'll
seriously i'll take one for the team
i'll take away our right to vote
to get the outcomes i want you know what
i mean
you're going to go down for that you're
literally going to go down i've said it
so many times
i've said it look at it like
i'm gonna take one for the team how they
voted for somebody with dementia you
know what i'm saying like what
like let me vote for somebody that won't
give me the the breath uh what is it the
the baby formula like you know we're
just not doing that good with these
decisions like i don't know
i mean we're back like let's let our
husbands vote for us
oh i'm tired with that
james is like solid guy like yeah yeah
james james and i very much agree on all
things
in the political landscape
he's probably more conservative or he's
probably more
of a stickler than i am i kind of laugh
this stuff off he's like
it's it's
i'll let him vote for me for sure
should we start a movement return our
rights
uh yeah i mean i'm shooting i'm down
like i have all my girlfriend like many
of my girlfriends are coming out and
they're saying look like we just don't
seem to be voting well okay like no
offense it's not a forte we'd be voting
based off of feelings but you know what
i found was interesting too
is it's a it's this new thing where
women are like oh yeah i'm queer and
it's like because that wasn't the tech
talk like i'm a black queer woman but
one time i went to the gym and these
other you know college fit white women
you know i'm in the midwest so they were
talking about like oh yeah like i'm
queer i'm like look making out with your
girlfriend at the bar when you're drunk
doesn't necessarily make you queer you
know what i mean like i don't what is
this like i'm a woman also i'm queer
like
why do you want to be included in
everything and that's women
yeah because no one because women don't
want to
feel like they're out of the party like
they want to be a part of everything and
um that was like a trend in college so
like if you made out remember katy perry
i kissed a girl and i like it like we
we've been there done that so like can
we just keep it pushing like why are we
still why are we trying to be queer
everyone like i don't understand next
you know it's like uh what's her name
what's that singer demi lovato who like
became non-binary overnight and she can
talk to aliens and like stuff like that
she was a beautiful woman
a beautiful woman and then she went like
non-binary queer
trans whatever like
and then just became weird like
literally the weirdest person
and speaks to it or sings to aliens so
i don't know
did we bring back exclusion bring back
exclusion